victimes 13 soldats américains le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu a condamné
ce qu'il qualifie d'acte odieux contre
des civils joe biden a promis de traquer
et de faire payer le prix aux groupes
terroristes dèche qui a revendiqué cette
attaque
la situation en afghanistan objet d'une
visite en italie de sergueï lavrov
dernière étape de sa tournée européenne
pour le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères
il a rencontré le premier ministre
italien mario draghi ainsi que le chef
de la diplomatie italienne les détails
dans cette édition
et puis nous parlerons de la situation
sanitaire avec une épidémie qui n'est
pas derrière nous c'est ce qu'a déclaré
hier le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand qui saluent l'accélération de la
campagne de vaccination à la famille
selon lui d'éviter le pire cet été pour
la première fois depuis le mois de
juillet la france a enregistré moins de
vingt mille cas en un jour mais la
situation reste préoccupante dans les
dom tom
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20 heures
le compte à rebours s'accélère le 31
août il n'y aura plus de troupes
américaines en afghanistan les
évacuations à bord de leurs avions
militaires ne seront plus possibles près
de 5400 afghans attendent leur tour dans
l'aéroport de kaboul une situation
extrêmement tendue au lendemain d'un
attentat revendiqué par des shows qui a
fait au moins 85 morts et plus de 160
blessés une attaque condamnée par le
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
qui demande que les auteurs soient
traduits en justice de son côté joe
biden a promis de traquer les
responsables
maxime à bolland
situation chaotique à kaboul quelques
jours avant la fin des évacuations l'
attaque terroriste revendiqué par le
groupe etat islamique a fait plus d'une
centaine de morts et encore davantage de
blessés le drame a eu lieu aux abords de
l'aéroport le site stratégique est
encore aux mains des occidentaux qui
procèdent à leur opération
d'exfiltration de leurs ressortissants
et de nombreux afghans voulant fuir le
pays mais ce jeudi aux alentours de 16
heures les terroristes ont frappé
l'explosion s'est produite à l'extérieur
de l'aéroport près du canal alors que
dans la soirée ont fait état d'au moins
deux explosions ce vendredi le pentagone
affirme qu'il n'y aurait eu qu'un seul
attentat suicide perpétré par un seul
auteur
l'hypothèse d'une deuxième explosion au
niveau de l'hôtel bar au voisin étant
désormais écarté
nous ne pensons pas qu'il y ait eu une
seconde explosion à l'hôtel barreaux ou
à proximité
l'attentât suicide a été commis par un
seul auteur nous ne savons pas comment
le rapport incorrect a été relayée mais
nous savons qu'il n'est pas surprenant
que dans la confusion provoquée par un
événement très déstabilisant comme
celui-ci des informations soient parfois
mal rapportés sont confuses
selon les premiers bilans au moins
treize soldats américains ont été tués
tard dans la soirée joe biden
visiblement touché a tenu à leur rendre
hommage évoquant des héros engagés dans
une mission dangereuse le président
américain a d'ores et d annoncé des
représailles contre le groupe etat
islamique
ne nous laisserons pas décourager par
des terroristes
nous ne les laisserons pas arrêter notre
mission et nous poursuivrons
l'évacuation nous répondrons avec force
et précision au moment et à l'endroit de
notre choix ces terroristes du groupe
etat islamique ne gagneront pas nous
allons secourir les américains là bas
nous ferons sortir nos alliés allemands
et notre mission continuera l'amérique
ne se laissera pas intimider à peine
terminée malgré l' attaque terroriste de
ce jeudi les opérations d'évacuation
continue tant bien que mal à l'aéroport
de kaboul près de cent mille personnes
l'ont déjà été exfiltré depuis la prise
de pouvoir des talibans
le 14 août dernier
selon joe biden le mouvement djihadiste
ne serait pas lié à l'attentât qui vient
d'avoir lieu près de l'aéroport de la
capitale afghane
jusqu'ici on ne m'a pas fourni de preuve
qu'il y ait une collusion entre les
talibans et le groupe etat islamique que
mener à bien ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui est ce qui devrait continuer
ce ne sont pas de bons gars les talibans
ce n'est pas ce que je suggère mais ils
ont à vifs intérêts comme beaucoup
d'entre vous l'ont signalé il aimerait
beaucoup savoir comment garder
l'aéroport ouvert ils n'ont pas la
capacité de le faire
2 les etats-unis et leurs alliés ont
désormais jusqu'à mardi pour continuer
les exfiltration depuis kaboul ce 31
août étant la date butoir pour le
retrait définitif des troupes
américaines sur place le compte à
rebours est désormais lancé avec une
menace terroriste extrêmement élevé
l'espagne l'italie ou encore le
royaume-uni ont annoncé aujourd'hui la
fin de leurs opérations d'évacuation la
france pourrait elle prolonger un peu
les siennes le point avec nicolas petit
les images ont fait le tour du monde des
afghans qui grimpe à même la carlingue
d'un avion dans l'espoir d'être exfiltré
depuis la mi août plusieurs milliers
d'entre eux ont été pris en charge grâce
aux efforts conjoints de la communauté
internationale partie prenante de cette
intervention l'italie a annoncé ce
vendredi au lendemain de l'attaqué de
kaboul la fin de ces opérations par la
voix de son ministre des affaires
étrangères
aurait ri partait dans les prochaines
heures le dernier c-130 va repartir de
l'aéroport de kaboul le dernier c-130
italien et à bord se trouveront le
consul tomasso cloud y l'ambassadeur
pontecorvo et tous les soldats les
carabiniers qui ont contribué à la
sécurité des opérations ces derniers
jours et je tiens à tous les remercier
et et nous sommes donc dans les
dernières heures des opérations
d'évacuation et à bord de ce dernier vol
il y aura tous ceux qui ont permis
d'exfiltrer environ 4900 citoyens
afghans en quelques jours et tous les
italiens qui ont demandé
comme l'italie l'espagne et le
royaume-uni honteuse aussi annoncé
mettre un terme à leur pont aérien
du côté de la france les choses ne sont
pas vraiment arrêté alors que jean
castex avait déclaré jeudi qu'à partir
de vendredi soir il ne serait plus
possible de procéder aux exfiltration le
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes s'est montrée ce vendredi un
peu moins définitif
les opérations finir prochainement elles
ont été évidemment interrompu perturbé
hier par cette attaque terroriste
terrible et donc on est heureux des
opérations qui vont s'achever rapidement
la date du 31 août est maintenu
et ça peut aller peut-être au-delà de ce
soir mais enfin nous devons rester
prudents sur ce sujet sur un total de
cent mille personnes exfiltré depuis la
mi août la france en a pris en charge un
peu plus de 2500 en grande majorité des
afghans dans un contexte où la menace
terroriste reste très grande les etats
unis ont eux confirmé leur départ de
kaboul le 31 août tout en affirmant
qu'il poursuivrait les évacuations
jusqu'au dernier moment pour les
milliers d'afghans qui n'ont pas eu la
chance d'embarquer le dernier recours
sera sans doute l'exode terrestre
d'après l'onu il pourrait y avoir
jusqu'à un demi million de réfugiés
afghans supplémentaires cette année sur
les routes de la région plus de deux
millions deux cent mille sont déjà
accueillies par les voisins iranien
pakistanais
et en france le conseil d'état a rejeté
hier la requête de quatre ressortissants
afghans il demandait que des mesures
urgentes soient prises pour faciliter le
rapatriement d'afghans en france au
titre de la réunification familiale mais
la plus haute juridiction administrative
française s'est en fait estimé
incompétente pour dicter sa conduite au
gouvernement une décision qui est tombée
le même jour que la tête de l'aéroport
de kaboul et selon adil abdul razeq
président de l'association des anciens
auxiliaires de l'armée française il est
urgent que la france accélère son
processus d'évacuation
le dernier attentat ne serait selon lui
que le début de la menace qui pèse sur
les familles afghanes bloqué à kaboul
je demande l'état français de facilité
de d'accélérer la procession la
procédure d'évacuation pour les les
anciens auxiliaire de qui ont les
anciens auxiliaires de l'armée française
et pour une vingtaine d'autres familles
qui ont déjà le statut résidents de
france de faciliter et d'accélérer la
procédure d'évacuation pour qu'il puisse
sauver leur vie et celle de leur famille
et on voit qu on ne reçoit aucune
réponse de la part des autorités
françaises bien sur sa selle de l'aude
ou de l'attak en fait
des bouts de la menace qui pèse
actuellement sur nos collègues qui
restent qui se retrouvent bloqués à
l'aéroport de kaboul nous espérons que
l'état français accélère et trouve une
solution pour ceux qui rentrent déjà
collaboré l'armée française et de sauver
leur vie et celle de leur famille mais
après le 31 août la procédure sera
encore compliqué et nos amis et ils sont
obligés de fuir de partir dans les pieds
limitrophes comme pakistan est avantagé
testant
une délégation française a rencontré
hier à doha des représentants des
talibans pour la première fois depuis
qu'ils ont pris le pouvoir en
afghanistan il aurait il aurait été
question de la situation à l'aéroport de
kaboul répétant une promesse déjà faite
à plusieurs pays le porte parole des
talibans a réaffirmé que chaque afghan
en possession de documents légaux pourra
voyager à l'étranger et les
installations appropriées seront fournis
pour les déplacements après l'ouverture
de la partie civile de l'aéroport cave
où se sont tenus les premières
discussions cette fois ci entre talibans
et tueur que le président r douanes
déclare que son pays ne peut s'offrir le
luxe de rester sans rien faire dans
cette région instable les talibans ont
repris les rênes du pays depuis près de
deux semaines riches aujourd'hui de
l'arsenal militaire laisser dans le pays
par les américains nicolas petit
depuis plusieurs jours ils les exhibe
fièrement des armes automatiques des
fusils de précision destinés aux tireurs
d'élite des munitions de différents
calibres mais aussi des véhicules
blindés les talibans disposent désormais
d'un armement à la fois complet est
récent en leur possession également des
hélicoptères comme celui ci laissé à
l'abandon par les forces de sécurité
afghanes lors de leur déroute d'après le
blog spécialisé au risque you and co.com
entre juin et août les talibans aurait
entre autres mis la main sur 2080 de
blindés légers une cinquantaine de canon
mortiers lourds et ils soient sans
douche art mais aussi au moins deux
avions 24 hélicoptères et 7 drones
militaires un butin conséquent est
susceptible de s'étoffer encore si l'on
en croit le conseiller à la sécurité
nationale à la maison blanche
nous n'avons évidemment pas une idée
claire du lieu où chaque pièce
d'équipement se trouve mais il est
certain qu'un grand nombre est tombé
entre les mains des talibans et nous
n'avons pas l'impression que les
talibans aient l'intention de nous les
rendre selon les chiffres de
l'inspecteur général pour la
reconstruction de l'afghanistan
les etats unis auraient dépensé 83
milliards de dollars en 20 ans pour
équiper l'armée afghane une somme
rondelette qui profitent aujourd'hui aux
talibans est les dirigeants américains
ne cachent d'ailleurs pas leur
inquiétude face à l'évolution de la
situation
il est évident que nous ne voulons pas
voir notre équipement entre les mains de
ceux qui risque d'agir contre nos
intérêts ou contre les intérêts du
peuple afghan et d'aggraver la violence
et l'insécurité en afghanistan
bien qu'une partie du matériel dernier
cri nécessite un certain savoir faire
tant pour son usage que pour son
entretien les talibans devraient pouvoir
s'adapter pour préparer leur départ
d'afghanistan
les américains avaient formé des afghans
dans ce domaine désormais autonome ils
ont pris le relais pour assurer à leur
tour la formation en échec après vingt
années de conflit en afghanistan le
pentagone a averti qu'il ne
s'interdisait pas d'aller directement
détruire tous ces armements désormais
aux mains des talibans
la situation en afghanistan au coeur des
discussions en italie le ministre russe
des affaires étrangères était à rome ce
vendredi il s'est entretenu avec le
premier ministre mario draghi et le chef
de la diplomatie italienne le point avec
notre envoyé spécial le mot namouh dès
lors et les échanges entre sergueï
lavrorv et luigi di maio on était je
cite très productif selon le chef de la
diplomatie italienne beaucoup de sujets
sur l'actualité internationale ont été
abordés bien évidemment la situation en
afghanistan était au coeur des
discussions et luigi di maio a indiqué
que l'italie serait très regardantes sur
l'évolution de la situation à kaboul
notamment pour les droits de l'homme les
droits des femmes mais également
concernant à l'acheminement de l'aide
écoutez le
et la priorité pour nous les thalys et
de garantir les droits de l'homme les
droits des femmes les droits des enfants
et les organisations internationales
doivent pouvoir avoir
accès sur le terrain pour pouvoir
acheminer une aide
à ceux qui en ont besoin
et notre communauté internationale doit
préparer cette
de son côté s'agace lavrov a fermement
condamné la dernière attaque à kaboul et
insisté sur les leçons à tirer de
l'occupation américaine écouter ya quand
même des
leçons à tirer après la libye après
l'irak après l'afghanistan encore une
fois on voit qu'il ne faut pas chercher
à importer imposer des systèmes de
valeurs à d'autres pays cela crée des
situations explosives et donc je pense
que quand on crée une politique
à long terme il faut sur les autres pays
il faut quand même prendre en compte les
réalités locales les deux homologues ont
également abordé le cas de la libye et
ont confirmé le retrait de leurs troupes
pays où la situation est au bord de
l'implosion est les questions
européennes ont également été abordés
sergueï lavrov le chef de la diplomatie
russe en a profité pour tacler les pays
européens et qui font la promotion d'un
sentiment antirusse écoutez nous avons
fait part de nos appréciations
de des dirigeants
de l'union européenne
qui maintiennent leurs humeurs antirusse
antirusse y ait un certain nombre de
pays russophones qui continue à être
actif que nous avons parlé de la
situation en ukraine
nous avons une position similaire
sur la nécessité de s'en tenir aux
accords de minsk mais nous avons donné
des exemples concrets
de la des amendements la constitution la
législation de crainhem qui sont
proposés qui vise à ne pas respecter des
accords de minsk et donc la situation
particulièrement complexe est des
échanges qui seront prolongées lors du
g20 sommet capital selon à luigi di maio
le chef de la diplomatie italienne un
sommet qui permettra notamment de
renforcer et d'approfondir la
coopération et des pays face aux
conflits internationaux et le décryptage
à présent de cette visite avec jean de
gliniasty l'ancien ambassadeur de france
en russie
d'italie et d'un front important si je
puis dire sur les questions de migration
l'itavi comme je les dis préside le g20
et donc
lcl à deux promus en quelque sorte une
concertation particulière avec les pays
qui ne sont pas membres du g7 les pays
du g20 mais dans un contexte spécifique
non afghans donc donc en fait italie va
chercher à
promouvoir une réunion particulière avec
la chine avec la russie avec l'inde avec
les pays du g7 et les pays de l'union
européenne en tout cas certains d'entre
eux pour adopter autant que possible une
ligne commune des lignes directrices
commune sur les questions migratoires et
les questions du terrorisme
et
en point sur la pandémie à présent avec
la russie qui approuve un cinquième
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 alors que
le pays traverse une nouvelle vague de
contamination et de décès liés en
majorité aux variants delta les
précisions avec notre correspondante à
moscou verhaeghe aux fans
un cinquième vaccin russe vient
d'obtenir l'enregistrement du ministère
de la santé il s'agit d'une déclinaison
du vaccin et pvac corona et pvac corona
n produit par le centre de recherche
vecteur de novossibirsk en sibérie cette
nouvelle version du vaccin permet de
produire le remède en grande quantité
plus facilement tout en conservant le
même niveau d'efficacité et de sécurité
selon les développeurs du vaccin il
serait performant contre tous les
variants existants ducourneau virus je
vous propose d'écouter oui grâce au
chili et beaucoup qui ribéry comme
nous avons justement choisi les parties
conservatrice du virus qui ne sont
presque pas sujette à des changements
dans le même temps elle se trouve dans
les parties vitales si le virus subi des
mutations dans ces parties il ne sera
sans doute pas viable une telle
descendance de virus ne se propagera pas
si vous aimez jezzine faso est
à présent le vaccin est efficace contre
les variants circulation ceux qui sont
rares et ceux qui sont les plus
répandues comme le delta maintenant il
n'y a pas besoin de modification c'est
l'un de ces avantages
il
le laboratoire russe se dit également
prêt à partager sa technologie avec
d'autres pays écoutez
nous sommes prêts à faire un transfert
de technologie à nos partenaires
potentiels non seulement en russie mais
aussi à l'étranger parce que le vaccin
dispose d'un nombre d' avantages
indiscutables et automatique
il est efficace contre divers variant sa
production est relativement peu onéreuse
il est facilement exploités à grande
échelle
le vaccin est conservée d'une manière
stable à une température de 2 à 8 degrés
au dessus de zéro donc il peut être
conservé dans un réfrigérateur normal on
peut utiliser des chaînes logistiques de
pointe pour le transport et comme j'ai
déjà dit il ne donne pas de symptômes
graves et sans danger
la russie produit actuellement 4e vaccin
spoutnik vespucci clyde consulter les
deux par le centre de recherche gamaleya
epibac corona conçu par le centre de
recherche d'acteurs et kobe vague conçu
par le centre de recherche tu m'as
qu'offrent les scientifiques russes
travaillent également sur un médicament
contre le co en à virus qui serait
capable de prévenir le développement de
la maladie une fois les personnes
infectées l' agence fédérale de médecine
et de biologie en charge de la
conception de ce traitement est en train
de terminer la deuxième phase des essais
cliniques et doit présenter son dossier
auprès du ministère russe de la santé
dès le mois de septembre
la tunisie toujours en difficulté dans
sa lutte contre le kobe 19 malgré
l'accélération de sa campagne de
vaccination alors que le pays traverse
également une crise politique majeure
les autorités sanitaires peine à
convaincre la population de se faire
vacciner pourtant le pays a reçu de
nombreux dons de sérum les précisions de
notre correspondant à tunis bassem
shellys une situation épidémique encore
volatile illustré par un taux de
positivité qui repart à la hausse après
des semaines de stabilité la tunisie
peine à sortir de cette quatrième vague
de coronavirus les tunisiens demeurent
toujours trop peu nombreux à se rendre
dans les centres de vaccination malgré
un taux important d'inscriptions sur la
plateforme et vax appel 34% de la
population s'est vu inoculer une
première dose de sérum anti qu'ovide
malgré les dons de vaccins qui
continuent d'affluer des quatre coins du
globe c'est une situation que déplorent
les autorités qui craignent ne pas
pouvoir atteindre limitée collective
alors qu'une nouvelle vague semble se
dessiner dans le pays mercredi deux
avions en provenance d'alger et de ryad
ont atterri à tunis avec à leur bord pas
moins de 800 mille doses de sérum du
matériel médical et des respirateurs de
quoi venir soulager les hôpitaux
tunisiens au bord de l'implosion face à
l'exaspération de la population et la
baisse des contaminés si on le
gouvernement avait décidé d'assouplir
les mesures de restriction comme le
couvre-feu qui était passée de 22 heures
à minuit des mesures qui semblent hélas
avoir eu un effet négatif encore
l'augmentation des contaminations le
ministère de la santé a fait état de
trois mille cinq cent cinquante deux
nouveaux cas de contamination pour la
journée du 24 août soit un taux de
positivité de 23 points 73 % contre 21 5
38% le 15 août dernier craignant une
nouvelle vague meurtrière le comité
scientifique tunisien envisagerait même
de rendre obligatoire le pass and i
terre à l'entrée des espaces publics
afin d'inciter les tunisiens se faire
vacciner dans les plus brefs délais
la situation sanitaire en france avec du
mieux le nombre de nouveaux cas est
passé sous la barre des 20000 cela
n'était pas arrivé depuis le mois de
juillet pas de quoi se réjouir pour
autant hier le ministre de la santé a
évoqué des taux d'incidence inégalée
notamment dans les bouches du rhône mais
surtout en martinique et en guadeloupe
les deux départements d'outre-mer sont
ceux qui comptent aujourd'hui le plus de
patients hospitalisés avec 11% du total
national olivier ferrand qui ne cesse
d'appeler les français à la vaccination
c'est elle qui est selon le ministre a
permis d'éviter le pire cet été
je le dis et la firme devant vous si
nous n'avions pas pu compter sur un
vaccin si nous n'avions pas mener une
vaste campagne de vaccination de toute
la population vaccinable c'est-à-dire
âgés de 12 ans et plus la quatrième
vague aurait pu être la pire des vagues
et que nous ayons connue elle aurait pu
entraîner des dizaines de millier de
contaminations supplémentaires chaque
jour des cas graves en masse parce que
le virus plus contagieux peut se
diffuser à une vitesse folle et que nos
hôpitaux auraient pu être débordés en
quelques semaines nous contraignant un
nouveau confinement au coeur de l'été
olivier ferrand qui a martelé que
l'épidémie n'était pas derrière nous
adore alors à quoi faut-il s'attendre
ces prochaines semaines nous avons posé
la question à jean paul steijns est
infectiologues ou au chu de grenoble
alpes
pour l'instant les hôpitaux c'est très
tendu ce n'est pas le débordement que
l'on connu il ya quelques mois mais
c'est quand même une situation très très
tendue alors est ce que là
la décroissance constatée depuis
seulement une semaine il faut être très
prudent et pas se répercuter d'ici 15
jours parce que c'est à peu près dé
l'air
d'ici quinze jours dans les hôpitaux on
l'espère mais rien n'est certain car on
va maintenant assister à la rentrée et
pas seulement la rentrée scolaire mais
le retour des vacanciers et ses
vacanciers comme chacun le sait
maintenant où on est et on était dans
des zones où la contamination étaient
extrêmes c'est-à-dire les côtes en gros
les côtes les côtes françaises les lieux
de mc n 2 de vacances et donc ils
rentrent chez eux tous ces gens là et
qu'est ce qui va se passer en termes de
contamination si nous ne sommes pas
assez vacciner donc ça c'est toute la
question c'est pour ça que je crois
qu'il faut rester très très prudents
ils exigent le retour des 2600
contractuels non renouvelés par le
rectorat cet après midi des dizaines de
manifestants se sont rassemblés à
l'appel de l'intersyndicale du second
degré de l'académie devant le rectorat
ils ont reproché notamment aux pouvoirs
publics d'avoir privilégié les économies
budgétaires au détriment de la qualité
de l'enseignement ils remettent en cause
le dispositif choix de l'école visant à
accompagner les jeunes diplômés désirant
enseigne et parfois aux dépens des plus
anciens écoutez les opposants présents
sur place
mais le rectorat dit tranquillement que
d'un point de vue de gestion ils ont
trop de trop titulaire par rapport aux
besoins qui sont exprimés il considère
qu' il n'y a pas de besoin donc pour
sait très bien que les besoins existent
dans les collèges dans les lycées on
sait très bien que les les élèves ont
besoin d'avoir cours dans des classes à
effectifs allégés on sait très bien que
il n'ya jamais trop d'enseignements que
donc tous ses collègues et de mettre en
place dans leurs collèges dans les
lycées il ya des manques et puis il ya
des choses est complètement aberrante
pour le suivi pédagogique il ya des
enseignants qui ont travaillé parfois
3,81 dans un établissement pour lesquels
le proviseur a demandé une main tient
parce qu'ils sont intégrés à l'équipe
etc et qui se retrouve aujourd'hui sans
affectation alors qu'à leur place il
peut y avoir d'autres personnes
éventuellement avec moins d'ancienneté
et que c'était m'enfin c'est cette
gestion à la petite semaine cette
gestion de la précarité là il ses
affects dans l'urgence est affecté dans
l'urgence et ne pas tenir compte des
préconisations du médical c'est ne pas
tenir compte des demandes de maintien
c'est ne pas tenir compte dans la donc
c'est on se retrouve dans des situations
où c'est n'importe quoi devant les
élèves à la rentrée dans les
établissements et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
prochain journal dans une trentaine de
minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté vous remercie de m'avoir
amitié
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir cette pratique obsessionnel
s'impose dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants
comme la condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir on ferait mieux de
faire référence à un passé dont on peut
être fier nous trouvons un autre exemple
des limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le client
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le meilleur de
ses caches aujourd'hui on vous parle de
l'union européenne et des moyens engagés
pour faire face à la crise